-Thank you very much Judy for
the generous introduction.
And I also owe a note
of sincere thanks
that the honor of being here
as a Radcliffe Fellow this year
to Liz Cohen, who's here in the
back, Rebecca Haley, who helps
keep us in order, and
of course to Susan
and Kenneth Wallach for
sponsoring the professorship
that I hold.
It's been a welcome
time to delve
into the sources
necessary to begin
a new project on procedure in
early Islamic law and society.
And it wouldn't have
been possible otherwise.
So thank you to them.
And thanks to all of
you for coming here.
So the title of my
talk, as you know,
is Qadi Justice--
Cases and Controversies
in Early Islamic
Law and Society.
I'll spend the bulk of my time
unpacking three such cases
and controversies in attempt
to better map the content
and significance of procedure
to early Islamic law.
Somewhat time in
tongue in cheek,
I call this project qadi
justice, where qadi simply
means judge in Arabic.
And I say tongue in
cheek because there's
a story behind this term.
Max Weber defined
qadi justice, spelled
in the proper German way.
He defined it as an arbitrary
judge sitting under a palm tree
dispensing justice
according to whim.
And he may have
gotten this notion
from reading Arabian Nights
as a manual for Islamic law.
Or perhaps more
charitably, he believed
the conventional narratives
of Muslim scholars themselves.
For them, the claim
with that Islamic law
was, in fact, an
unchanging sacred law
that descended from on high.
They tended to
discuss it in terms
of substantive legal
rulings in their manuals.
And they didn't pay much
attention to procedure.
If Islam had a system
where the law was
all text and no
procedure, then a judge
might indeed have to
decide cases by whim.
There'd be no escape valve
otherwise, as Weber supposed.
But I have evidence
to suggest precisely
the opposite in
ways that may make
us redefine Islamic law itself.
My main contention is
that judges developed
robust procedures to help
define Islamic law in response
to changing social and political
circumstances during Islam's
founding period, by which I
referred to the long founding
period from the seventh
to 11th centuries.
These procedures were part
and parcel of Islamic law,
even though they are rarely
contained in its manuals.
So before elaborating
on that claim,
I'll point out that the old
Weberian notion of Islamic law,
this qadi justice, the judge
sitting under a tree, it's
unfortunately the case that
it dangerously persists today
as many who subscribe to
or comment on Islamic life
tend to believe
that it is somehow
divinely determined,
and therefore static.
So let me start with
the first case, which
highlights the role of procedure
and change through a notion
of the Islamic law of doubt.
This curious episode in
early Islamic history
illustrates the
problems posed by doubt
in Islamic criminal law.
And I'll call it the case of
the falsely accused butcher.
Not long after Islam's advent
in the seventh century,
a type of early police force
in a small Arabian town
was out patrolling.
Members of the patrol came
across a man in the town ruins
holding a bloodstained
knife in his hand,
and standing over the body of
another man who had obviously
just died or been killed.
The patrol arrested
the man with the knife.
An upon arrest, he confessed.
I killed them.
The suspect was brought
before Ali, the beloved cousin
and son-in-law of
the prophet Muhammad,
who had died less than three
decades before that in 632.
Ali was the fourth caliph,
according to the Sunni account
of successors to the prophet.
And he was the first imam in
the competing Shia account.
He presided over criminal
trials in his capacity
as leader of the young Muslim
community from 656 to 661,
as had the prophet before him.
And upon hearing the
defendant's story,
Ali reportedly sentenced
him to death in accordance
with the Islamic
law of retaliation
or of [INAUDIBLE] for
homicide and personal injury,
a life for a life.
Before the sentence
was carried out,
another man rushed forward,
telling the executioners don't
be so hasty.
Don't kill him.
I did it, he said.
Ali turned to the condemned
man incredulously.
What made you confess to a
crime that you didn't commit?
The man explained that
he thought that Ali never
take his word over that of
the patrolman who had perhaps
witnessed the crime, or at
least witness the crime scene
wherein all signs pointed
to him as the perpetrator.
In reality, the man
explains, he was
a butcher who had just
finished slaughtering a cow.
And immediately
after the slaughter,
he needed to relieve himself.
So he entered into the
town ruins, bloody knife
still in hand.
Upon return, he came
across the dead man,
and he actually stood
over him in concern.
It was then that the
patrol encountered him.
And figuring that he
couldn't plausibly
deny having committed
the crime, he
confessed to what
seemed to be obvious,
and decided to leave the
matter in God's hands.
The second man offered
a corroborating story
and explained that
he was the one who
had murdered the man
for money, and then
fled upon hearing sounds
of the patrol approaching.
On his way out, he passed the
butcher entering the area,
and then watched the events
unfold just as the butcher had
described them.
Once the butcher was
condemned to death,
however, the second man felt
compelled to step forward.
He didn't want the blood
of two men on his hands.
So this episode--
and again, we'll
refer to it as the
case of the falsely
accused butcher--
depicts the difficulties
that early and medieval Muslim
judges faced when attempting
to apply Islamic criminal law
without the benefit of being
able to discern the facts,
the law, or the morality
of punishment with
any certainty.
As for the facts, confession
or witness testimony usually
sufficed to establish guilt
in Islamic criminal laws
of murder.
But here, Ali as judge
was presented only
with circumstantial and,
eventually, contradictory
evidence.
There were these competing
confessions which cancelled
each other out.
And there was no
witness testimony
beyond the patrol that only
witnessed the crime scene, not
the actual crime itself.
As for the Islamic
law of homicide,
the Quran and other
foundational texts
contained clear rules that
retaliation applied only
to intentional murder.
But those rules didn't
cover the case before Ali.
There was no claim
of premeditation,
at least not for the butcher.
And as for the morality, and
consequently the legitimacy
of punishment, Ali
also had to decide
whether to enforce or avoid
the textual role of punishment
if he decided that it
applied in the face
of procedural uncertainties
about the law and the facts.
And he chose to
avoid punishment.
Now the question is
why and to what extent?
And the answer is shrouded
by a tangled web that
took Muslim jurists
centuries to weave,
and therefore takes serious
historical work to unravel,
which is what I do it in my
book that Judy mentioned,
Doubt in Islamic Law.
But don't worry, I won't spend
centuries unraveling that story
here.
I'll cut to the center.
Muslims developed a
robust set of procedures
that they believed
were consistent
with Islamic legal
rules and values
to make doubt and avoidance
of punishment on its basis
a central pillar of
Islamic criminal law.
So that's the book
in a nutshell.
And read it for more
if you want to see how.
So myriad episodes like
the case of the falsely
accused butcher recur in
early Islamic legal sources.
And Muslim jurists explain such
cases consistently with respect
to doubt.
They took cases like
this one as a precedent.
And based on it,
they then promoted
a surprisingly
extensive tendency
of extending the benefit of
the doubt to the accused.
They packaged that tendency
in the form of a legal maxim
and oft repeated
saying whereby they
counsel judges to avoid criminal
punishment in cases of doubt.
This was repeated
over and over again.
Avoid criminal punishments
in cases of doubt.
So I call this statement
Islamic laws' doubt canon.
And it's one of many
Islamic legal maxims that
were rooted in past cases
and in judicial practices
from those past cases
as a way of elaborating
a procedural rule.
That became part and
parcel of Islamic law.
And it's part of
Islamic law, I argue,
even though it manifests
less as text in the law books
and more as procedure in
the form of legal practice
that comes from other
sources, which I'll discuss.
Now one more note about
doubt before we move on.
For anyone familiar with
American criminal law,
I should note that
the Arabic term
for doubt in this canon,
[ARABIC], was a term of art.
And you have a handout.
That's the first
term on the handout.
And you can ignore
it thereafter.
And I'll tell you when
you can pick it up again.
It assumes a much
more expansive meaning
than the common conception
of reasonable doubt
that we have in American law.
So rather than presenting a
principally fact based approach
to standards of proof,
the Islamic doctrine
covered factual uncertainties,
legal ambiguities,
even extralegal considerations
that I call moral doubt.
And moreover, the
Islamic doctrine of doubt
corresponds to analogous
American doctrines
as seemingly disparate as
the principle of legality,
the rule of lenity, which
instructs judges to construe
criminal statutes narrowly
in cases of doubt,
the presumption of innocence,
the requirement for proof
beyond a reasonable
doubt as to the facts,
mens rea requirements
or the state of mind
having to be criminal before
criminal culpability can be
assigned, mistake,
ignorance, impossibility,
and other potentially mitigating
circumstances, and even mercy.
And the concept of [ARABIC]
or doubt in Islamic law
also covered notions
unique to Islamic law.
There's a notion of
contractual doubt
whereby a contract could
create a cause for doubt
as to criminal liability.
And of interpretive
doubt, whereby
multiple legal
interpretations that
were considered equally valid
yet different in Islamic law
could also create a
cause for doubting
whether a criminal
sanction would apply in one
circumstance where
the underlying act
would have been permissible
in another school of thought.
And we can talk more about that.
So why should we care about
doubt or the role of procedure
to which it points?
This current project
on qadi justice
which seeks to elucidate
the role of procedure
in early Islamic law grows
out of that earlier project
on doubt.
So in the book, Doubt
in Islamic Law, which
was published
earlier this year, I
what turns out to have been
a long history of discretion
and doubt in Islamic criminal
law as I just described.
But the fact that I published
a book on the subject
is not the reason we should
care about the Islamic history
of doubt or about the judicial
procedures that grew out of it.
Instead, I submit that the
procedure is important here
because it reveals
an underrecognized,
but I think all important
aspect of Islamic legal history
that may redefine notions
of Islamic law itself.
Now if that seems like
a grand claim, it is.
But let me explain what I
mean by that with respect
to both modern and
political developments,
or modern political developments
and scholarly debates
concerning Islamic law.
And I'm more concerned
with the scholarly debates
as a historian.
So it will be my focus.
But I want to say something
about the modern political
relevance as well.
So as for the modern
political developments,
the history of
doubt and procedure
matters for ongoing questions
of Islamic law today.
For starters, Islamic
law has reemerged
in the past half century
in constitutional
and in criminal context.
Since the 1970s,
over 29 countries
have incorporated an
Islamic law or sharia
clause into their
constitutional text,
a clause saying
Islamic law shall
be a source or
the source of law,
or they've announced
intentions to do so as has
the Gambia just a few days ago.
And during the same period,
at least a dozen states
have passed Islamic
criminal law codes
or applied Islamic criminal
law in various regions.
And these countries range
from Iran, Pakistan, and Saudi
Arabia to provinces in
Malaysia, northern Nigeria,
and now in Syria.
In this country there
are raging debates
about the definitions
of Islamic law
and the role for doubt or
discretion in criminal law.
And to be sure, many of those
who seek to apply Islamic law,
and particularly Islamic
criminal law in these areas,
adopt ill conceived
and ahistoric versions
of rigidly harsh Islamic
criminal law, particularly
in places like northern
Nigeria, Mali, Iraq.
And the barbarism that results
from this ignorant application
has prompted, more
than anything,
fears of Islam punishments,
or Islamic law more generally.
In fact, those
punishments have sometimes
come to define the
face of sharia itself.
It's often left
untranslated in order
to highlight its exoticism and
the danger that it can evoke.
So the book called into question
this erroneous but popular
notion of Islamic law,
which incidentally
is upheld by many
Muslim adherents
and non-Muslim critics alike.
And to put that in
more vivid terms,
you might say that the Isis
leader and Donald Trump or Ben
Carson share an idea
of what sharia is.
The notion is that
Islamic law is
a divine legal tradition with
little room for discretion
or doubt.
And what I want to
intervene and say
is that despite the contemporary
popularity of that notion,
it turns out, based
on research today,
to have been far outside the
mainstream of Islamic law
for most of its history.
And the surprising
reality is that, as we
saw in the aftermath of the case
of the falsely accused butcher,
instead of rejecting doubt,
historically Muslim scholars
embraced it.
And they came to
hold it so closely
that it came to be at the
heart of Islamic criminal law.
And through the doubt
canon-- and here
is where the new
project comes in-- it
was Islamic criminal
procedure that
came to be central to notions
of Islamic criminal law itself.
And that was manifested
through this maximum
here, the doubt canon.
Avoid criminal punishment
in cases of doubt.
So in the political
and policy arenas
today, this history
is significant
not only to further
our understanding
of a forgotten notion of
doubt in early Islamic law,
but because of the importance
for early Islamic law
to modern interpretations.
In many ways akin to
conservative visions
of the American legal
tradition, Islamic law
is a textualist and
originalist legal tradition.
Appeals to Islamic
law are really
appeals to the founding
moment or founding
history of Islamic law in which
directives from the prophet
and from other
authoritative figures
were most authoritative,
just like references
to the American founding fathers
carries some weight in debates
about American constitutional
and statutory interpretation.
So that's a word about
the political and policy
significance of discretion,
doubt, and procedure.
As for the scholarly
debates about Islamic law,
the history of doubt and
the role of procedure
matters for gaining a
better understanding
of the nature of Islamic law
during that founding period.
Any misunderstanding,
in my view,
has to do with impoverished
understanding of Islamic law
from a narrow use of sources
to enrich those understandings.
So my approach
combines the tools
of a historian and a lawyer.
Wearing both hats,
I approach questions
of interpretation
in early Islamic law
and society with
insights from theories
of constitutional and
statutory interpretation,
which is a field, at least
in the American context,
that's witnessed significant
advances in the past few years
or decades.
So starting from
two basic insights,
one that procedure is law,
and vice versa, and two,
that interpretation
helps define and manage
institutional and
social relations.
I've been able to identify
ways in which procedure
and interpretation helped
construct and were constructed
by institutions, values,
and social norms that
informed Islamic legal rules.
Moreover, by taking Islamic
law as law in the broad sense
that modern lawyers
understand law,
and by thus examining a
broad range of sources
for Islamic law and society
in its early period,
my project speaks both to
the nature of Islamic law
and to theories
of interpretation
with which all legal
systems are concerned,
but which typically
developed with respect only
to American or Western
legal traditions.
So in that sense, I also
aim for this project
to help critique and expand
our notions of procedure
and of legal interpretation.
My examination then
of qadi justice
is necessary to round out
the rather square notion
of Islamic law in the
books at the expense
of the law in action, both for
a more accurate understanding
of Islam's early
history, and for a more
expanded notion of modern legal
theory in comparative context.
So with that long
introduction to the subject,
I'll proceed within the
remainder of the talk
as follows.
In part one, I'll layout
some basic building blocks
that will help map the
players, the legal sources,
and the institutional
structures that
are integral to
understanding Islamic law
and so that you have some
blocks to play with, as it were.
In part two, I'll give
an example-- I'm sorry,
in part three I'll
give an example
of a case from a literary
source in 10th century
Baghdad that
exemplifies problems
of caliphal excesses
in punishment
to which the jurists writing
about doubt and procedure,
and developing procedure
were responding.
And then in part
four I'll circle back
to the question of the sources
for this current project
and the importance of an
expanded set of sources
to better
understanding the scope
and content and operation of
Islamic law in its early period
with respect to procedure.
What is the availability,
significance,
and use of this wide range
of sources for developing
the early history of
Islamic law through a focus
on actual cases-- or reported
I should say-- reported cases
and controversies.
In short, I'll argue that
these cases are important not
for their historical
truth value,
but to uncover the legal aims
to which jurists put them,
and to chart how and why
judicial procedure emerge
from certain developments in
early Islamic law and society
that they represent.
And this last part is
essentially a [INAUDIBLE]
or a mini version of the project
that I'm working on this year.
And so I very much welcome
comments in that vein.
So on to part two, the basic
building blocks of Islamic law.
And here is where your
handouts come in handy.
There are two basic
building blocks
that lay the foundation on
which medieval Muslim jurists,
the main players, historically
constructed Islamic law
and procedure--
the textual sources
and the institutional
structures.
As for the textual
sources, there
is the Quran, which
is Muslim scripture.
And this is a picture of
one first century Hijri
or seventh century
manuscript and hadith,
or prophetic reports of the
words and actions of Muhammad.
Now Muslims believe
that Muhammad
was a prophet who received
revelations directly from God
and that he recorded the
Quran during his lifetime
in the seventh century.
And so this is the first
textual source of Islamic law.
It's constitutional text.
In addition, early Muslims
recorded the prophet's
statements in multiple
books, collecting
thousands of prophetic
reports over the course
of two centuries.
And so this forms a
second textual source.
Now significantly,
none of these sources
were-- of the second type--
were contained in a single book.
There's no single law code.
There are thousands of
reports that were gathered
over the course of time.
Now Muslims took
Mohammed's statement
to be normative
sources of Islamic law
when he issued those
statements in his capacity
as a divinely inspired prophet
and when they could ascertain
the authenticity of these
multitude of sources
that they were recording some
decades, and in some cases,
centuries after the
prophet's death.
But they didn't look to these
statements as normative sources
where the authenticity
could not be ascertained,
or where he was speaking
in his personal capacity--
for example,
expressing preferences
that had little to do with law.
In this personal
capacity, even he
was bound to the rules
of the divine law.
And the thorny task
then for hadith scholars
and for jurists dealing with
such a fluid textual corpus
was distinguishing the
personal from the prophetic,
and the authentic from
those falsely attributed.
Now Muslims also believed
that God legislated
a comprehensive set of
laws through these two
textual sources, the
Quran and hadith.
Those laws included a short
list of fixed criminal laws.
And that's [ARABIC],
the third on your list.
And these fixed
criminal laws were also
supposed to provide the
upper limits of punishment
for any discretionary
penalties that a caliph rather
than a judge might impose.
The idea was that criminal law,
more starkly than other areas
of law, expressed
Islam's absolute form
of divine legislative supremacy.
God was the sole legislator,
so legislator with a big L.
And he tolerated no
departure from the text.
In the textualist strict
constructionist version
of Islamic law, divine
legislative supremacy
meant applying Islamic
criminal laws broadly
whenever there was some
text and some evidence
to suggest cause for
punishment, and otherwise
to suspend judgment altogether.
And this approach
stood in stark contrast
to the one that went
out through the doubt
canon and the development
of procedure through it.
And that was the push to
construe text narrowly
in the style of the rule of
lenity, American law, whenever
there were ambiguities that
arose from applications of law
to facts.
And it also cautioned judges to
avoid conviction and punishment
in the style of reasonable
doubt in American law
when the evidence was
questionable to proving
the claim with
absolute certainty.
So this brings us to the
second building block,
the institutional structures.
Historically
Islamic governments,
like all premodern
government, did not
have three
constitutionally defined
separate branches of power.
They often did not have
Constitutions Instead,
there was an informal
constitutional arrangement
that unfolded in
the Islamic context
after the prophet's
death in 632.
In this scheme, a class
of scholar jurists
asserted the authority
to interpret Islamic law,
to say what the law is.
And monarchical rulers
called caliphs enforced it.
Now between the two,
there where judges
whom the caliph appointed,
but who looked to the jurists
for definitions of Islamic law.
In some sense the
jurists were learned
scholars of the law,
much like professors.
But unlike professors,
Muslim jurist's
definitions of Islamic
law actually mattered.
They were crucial
for definitions
of Islamic law itself and
for questions of legitimacy.
So this much is now well
known in the literature.
We have a basic outline
of three institutions.
We have the jurors
and their actors--
we have the jurists, the
judges, and the caliphs.
But the existing
scholarship does not
give us the full picture of
how Muslim jurists expanded
their discretion
over Islamic law,
and how they did so with
respect to procedures
informed by the social
and political realities
of their times.
So this is a part of
the picture that I
see to fill in with reference
to the cases and controversies
from the early period.
And to that end, I argue
that in response the cases
like the case of the
falsely accused butcher,
Muslim jurists of the time
appealed to authoritative cases
to identify, define,
and expand procedures
to better guide legitimate
criminal punishment.
So to add some
color to that claim,
I'll use a 10th
century case that
inspired judges of the time to
construct and better articulate
procedures based on the
more authoritative cases
like the falsely accused butcher
case from the seventh century
and just after.
Now I said I wanted to
add some more color.
And the 10th century case
is actually really colorful.
It's called the
case of the tailor
and military sexual misconduct.
It's essentially two
cases wrapped up in one.
And the first load case has
the do with debt repayment.
Now in the eastern
section of Baghdad
sometime in the late
1900s-- and Baghdad
was a round city that
had four quadrants
at the time-- an
elder merchant came
to the local judge, [INAUDIBLE]
to demand repayment of a debt
from one of the soldiers.
The soldier had been
avoiding repayment.
And every time the
merchant went to demand it,
there would be a guard
at the soldier's home
brushing off the request.
So even if the judge could
issue a decision declaring
that payment was due,
he had no authority
to enforce the decision
or to force payment.
And accordingly, he had
to submit a complaint
to the caliphal court of
[INAUDIBLE], the caliph
at the time, for enforcement.
The vizier, who worked
under the caliph
and who first entertained
such claims, [INAUDIBLE],
received the complaint.
But he didn't do
anything about it.
So the case seemed
hopeless, as if there
was no justice to be had.
The judge applying Islamic law
might have entered a judgment
requiring repayment, but he
lacked enforcement authority.
The caliph's vizier who did
have enforcement authority
ignored the complaint.
And it seemed that
the soldier was
to be left to do
exactly as he pleased.
But then a friend of the
merchant intervened, presumably
one of the officials
of the town.
And he directed him
to a local tailor.
The tailor, upon
hearing the case,
accompanied that
merchant and the official
to the soldier's house.
And they were immediately
well received.
The soldier said come
in, how can I help?
What can I do for you?
And the tailor told him
the story that the merchant
had recounted to him.
Immediately, the soldier offered
to give whatever money he had.
All I have is 5,000
dirhams or silver coins.
Please ask him to accept that,
he said to the tailor, along
with these riding reins
made of gold and silver
as my security deposit until
I can come up with the rest.
And so the merchant
took possession of both,
and he was satisfied.
Now back at the ranch, or the
tailor shop to be more precise,
of course the merchant
wanted to know
what was up with the tailor.
Why had the tailor
held such sway
over this otherwise obstinate
and intransigent soldier?
And so the tailor rather
reluctantly told the story
as follows.
And this is the second case,
the really colorful case
of the tailor and the
military sexual misconduct.
So the tailor had
been the prayer leader
at the local mosque, again in
this eastern section of Baghdad
near to his tailoring
shop, for over 40 years.
And so one day on his
way home from work,
he passed by a drunken
Turkish soldier
and saw him grab a
beautiful young woman who
was just passing by his home.
And he forced her
into his house.
She called out for help.
No one was around to respond.
And so the tailor took
it upon himself to help.
He knocked on the door.
He kindly asked the soldier
to let the women go.
And in response, he got hit on
the head with a mace and almost
got knocked out.
So the tailor slowly
made his way back
to the mosque to pray
the late evening prayer.
And when he was done, he
tried to rally all those
in attendance to go
confront the Turkish soldier
and to free the woman.
The group agreed and they
went to the soldier's door.
And then mayhem ensued.
The soldier came out flanked
by a number of soldiers
around him.
And they all began beating
up this group of people who
had just come from the mosque.
And they again hit the poor
tailor in the head, this time
injuring him even more.
He barely recovered,
barely made it home.
So the tailor was
annoyed to say the least.
And so he thought,
what can I do?
So he devised a scheme.
I bet if I were to make the
call to prayer early, the call
to the dawn prayer, the Turkish
soldier, who was clearly drunk,
would think the dawn
had come, in which case
he would release the
woman, not wanting
to be seen with her
in the light of day.
Then he figured, that would
be the lesser of two evils.
Both actions were
considered impermissible,
either him making the call to
prayer outside of its appointed
time or allowing a woman to
be raped by this soldier.
Of the two, he figured
it was a lesser sin
to call for prayer outside
of its appointed time.
And he may have had another
scheme in mind as well.
Because the police
chief immediately
asked why this man had made
this untimely call to prayer,
and commanded that he go
see the caliph immediately.
So it was just as the
tailor wanted perhaps.
He got an audience with the
caliph, who actually had power.
The caliph, [INAUDIBLE],
asked, well why did you
make the call to prayer
at the time that you did?
And the tailor recounted
the whole story,
to which the caliph
then ordered the police
chief to summon the Turkish
soldier and the woman
immediately.
The woman was
questioned separately.
And she confirmed the tale
or the narrative of events
that the tailor had told.
And then the soldier was
asked about what happened.
And even he confirmed
the narrative of events.
And so the caliph
looked at him and said,
well are all the
stipends and the land
and the position that
you have from being
a senior soldier insufficient
to stop you from committing acts
of disobedience against
God, and from compromising
my power and my authority?
And the soldier was at a loss,
unable to give an answer.
The caliph then ordered
that he be shackled, beaten,
and eventually had him
executed and thrown
into the Tigris River.
The caliph concluded by saying
to the tailor, [ARABIC],
a term for wise man.
Any wrongs you see,
whether large or small,
even if it's
against this person-
and he pointed to
his police chief--
please don't pass by it,
but stop by and forbid it.
And if anything happens to you
or is not accepted from you,
or if anyone violates the
law, the signal between us
will be that you'll
make the call to prayer
at a time like this.
And I will hear your
voice and summon you,
and do what I've
just done to whoever
does not agree with you.
So news of this incident
and the caliphs admonition
spread amongst the
local officials
and the soldiers alike.
And from that day onward,
never did this tailor ask them
for anything, whether
to enforce the law
or to cease violating the law,
except that they obeyed him
without question and with
a great amount of deference
in the same way that the
soldier displayed when asked
to repay the merchant's debt.
Then the tailor concluded
the case saying, never
have I needed to make an
untimely call to prayer again.
So such was the case.
Where does the case come from?
Instead of an archive of
court records, which do not
exist for this early
period, the case
comes from a literary source.
It's contained in one of
the work of the famous judge
and literary critic who hailed
from Baghdad in modern day
Iraq.
His name was [INAUDIBLE]
Al-Muhassin al-Tanukhi,
who died in 994.
And this judge came from a
well known family of judges.
Judgeships seem
to be hereditary.
And they worked closely
with the Abbasid caliphs
in Baghdad and in
surrounding lands.
He also had a front row
seat to unfolding plays
of law and society in both law
courts and in royal courts.
So he's known less for
his explicitly legal works
than he is for his
literary compilations.
And those literary
compilations are all court
focused anecdotes that provide
rich insight into themes
of early Islamic
law and society.
There are two books in
particular that are important.
One is the book called Relief
After Adversity, [ARABIC].
And the second has
been translated
as Table Talk of a
Mesopotamian Judge, [ARABIC].
Both of these are at
the bottom of your sheet
under literary sources.
So theses courts aren't
unique to Tanukhi, this judge.
The first known author of the
genre was {?_[INAUDIBLE]
who died in 894.
And he wrote Collecting Cases
and Controversies of Relief
after Adversity, [ARABIC],
over a century before.
But Tanukhi's work is the
most well known in the genre.
It's the most expansive and
it's the best preserved.
And according to Tanukhi himself
in these works, he wrote down
or he compiled the work based
on written and oral informants,
and included stories about
contemporary officials, judges,
and other acquaintances
in the courts.
So worth noting here is that
this source and the case
it depicts are atypical
sources of Islamic law,
unlike that of the
falsely accused butcher
from Islam's founding period,
which is found in some
of the early foundational text.
But I want to suggest that
this case and other cases
like it nevertheless
did affect the jurists
of the time in the construction
of Islamic law and procedure.
And it did so through affecting
the readings of the earlier,
more precedential cases.
From my reading of
multiple sources,
it seems that the judges
or the jurists circulating
in 10th century Baghdad
where these events reportedly
unfolded, they were
disturbed by at least
three aspects of the case.
First, there was a marked
departure from Islamic law,
and a marked lack of procedure.
It was apparent in the
underlying case, the debt
repayment case,
that the judge had
no discretion or no
authority to enforce
the law of debt repayment.
And more significantly,
in the second case
of the tailor and the
military sexual misconduct,
the caliphal court did
not appeal to the judge
or to any Muslim jurist to
decide the fate of the soldier.
He didn't apply any
particularly robust procedures.
And he didn't seem to
follow Islamic law at all.
So second, the caliph asserted
absolute authority then
over the law in ways that were
at odds with the basic building
blocks of Islam law
that we covered.
And those basic building
blocks were important
because they undergirded the
entire system of legitimacy
for the caliph himself.
If he wasn't applying Islamic
law, as defined by the jurists,
then he didn't have
justification or legitimacy
to his rule.
And that's just a statement
of the subtle understanding
of the sources of legitimacy
for early caliphs.
And then third, and
perhaps most importantly,
the case arguably
exemplifies caliphal excesses
in punishment, to
which the response was
jurists' construction of
procedures at that time based
on earlier cases.
So in executing the
man without what
we might call
Islamic due process,
the caliph was at odds with all
authorized Islamic punishments
for the crimes involved,
theft or failure
to repay debt, personal
injury, and rape.
And his concern had more
to do with protecting
his own authority
than it had to do
with ensuring the Islamic
law basis for public order.
And this was a thing
that was unacceptable
to the jurists
operating at that time.
They responded by articulating
robust criminal procedures
to counter the caliphal
excesses in punishment.
So in short, the
case is important not
for its historic value as
to what actually happened,
but for the interpretive
output that it
bore in the 10th century
with respect to early cases.
It was used to define the
very procedure with respect
to ongoing controversies
that emerged
from episodes like the case
of the tailor and other cases.
And obviously this is
from a literary source.
And so it's not a report, most
likely, of an actual case.
But taken in the aggregate, such
cases reported in these sources
and others give us an idea
of the types of controversies
that were live at the time.
And judges, in response,
used it to buttress
the importance of procedure
for Islamic legitimacy.
When the new rulers
in the 10th century
pressed for execution orders
or to otherwise violate
Islamic laws as they did
in the case of the tailor,
the procedures that the
jurists articulated in response
could be used by judges to
say that their hands were tied
by Islamic law, understood
not just as text,
but as text and procedures that
would prevent such executions.
So with that background,
we're equipped
to circle back to the
question of the sources
for this overall
project on qadi justice
in which I think to map the
extent and growth of procedure.
So returning to the
question I earlier posed,
what is the availability,
significance, and use
of a wide range of
sources for developing
the early history of Islamic
law through this sort of focus
on cases and controversies.
In the doubt project,
I got an inkling
of the significance
and growth of procedure
in the course of uncovering an
obscure history of discretion
and doubt in Islamic
criminal law.
This project on
qadi justice builds
on that one with a more direct
look at the significance
of procedure and
the challenges it
poses to our understanding
of the meaning and operation
of early Islamic
law in criminal law,
but in other legal
contexts as well.
More specifically
in this project,
I will further explore the
development of procedure
and the ways in which
it informs the use
or inform the use of
discretion in context
that span criminal law, family
law, and commercial law.
And I do so by appealing
to a wider range of sources
than does the typical
Islamic law scholar in order
to gain a richer sense of
the social and legal history.
It is in that vein that
the cases and controversies
that we've discussed today
help provide vivid examples
of my overarching claim.
And that is that
judges developed
a robust set of
procedures to help define
Islamic life in
response to changing
social and political
circumstances during Islam's
founding period.
And these procedures,
moreover, were part and parcel
of Islamic law itself,
even though they're rarely
contained in the early
Islamic law books or manuals.
So let me end then by
stepping back even farther
from the particular
subject matter at hand
to lay out the larger
picture into which
this project on qadi justice.
And I'll say then a word
about law and society.
So scholars of law
and society commonly
divide up the world
into spheres of law
in the books and law in action.
And the dichotomy refers to
connections and disjunctions
between rules contained
in legislation
and other legal documentation
on the one hand,
and to real world events
on the other hand.
How is the
administration of justice
affected by
considerations like access
to courts, social status,
political context?
And reflexively, how
do these considerations
affect how laws are
made and modified
in the Islamic context?
So answers to
these questions are
essential for rounding out
the frame of any legal system
beyond the skeletal
composition written
on the pages of the law books.
And they're also
the very questions
underlying debates
about the nature of law,
and particularly Islamic
law, to the extent
that this is a religious
legal system that
is in fact constructed, I
argue, by varied institutions
and evolving social
norms, despite the claims
to divine legal
origins and authority.
Our contemporary view of courts
and of the lines connecting
them to society, to help shape
early Islamic legal history,
it's hazy at best.
This book project
on qadi justice
aims to sharpen those
lines by examining
the inner workings of the
courts and the administration
of Justice in Abbasid,
Baghdad, and surrounding lands
during this early
period of Islamic law.
And the court aims
are to investigate
the extent to which
judges constructed
a regular set of
procedures-- often
in the form of legal maxims
as we saw on the criminal law
context of the doubt cannon--
which in turn help construct
the operation of law.
The aim is also
to better identify
ways in which judges
drew on evolving
societal norms to
inform their conceptions
and their use of both procedure
and law, or procedure as law.
And finally it's to gauge the
extent of continuity and change
in the functional
use of procedure
as law over time and place.
So to be sure, this
approach differs radically
from the conventional narrative.
As I noted earlier, the typical
understanding of Islamic law is
that it's a secret law,
in the words of Max Weber,
which cannot change through
human interpretation.
And indeed Muslim
judges and jurists
themselves claim simply to
execute divine legal text.
But then again,
what judge doesn't?
The United States
Supreme Court justices
claim not to insert
their own preferences
or to allow extra
legal considerations
into the law, preferring to
simply call balls and strikes,
as Chief Justice John Roberts
said during his confirmation
hearings.
Scholars of constitutional
law, of legislation
and statutory
interpretation however,
have applied insights
from legal realism
and legal process, critical
theory, game theory,
and public choice, and the
lessons of historical method
to expose the fallacy
of neutrality,
the neutrality claim
in American law.
And my book project seeks to
apply those same basic insights
and definitions of law to
the different structures,
histories, and
origins of Islam law,
with a focus on the
construction of law
through procedure and
other social norms.
So in conclusion,
in the end, I'm
in a sense arguing for a
redefinition of Islamic laws.
Against conventional
narratives of it,
I contend that Islamic
law is not just
a narrow range of
texts or textual rules,
but that it includes a
robust set of procedures
central to the actual definition
and operation of Islamic law.
And I further claim that those
procedures, and thus the law
itself, were dynamic,
both developed
in response to institutional
and social context.
And they change over time.
Many we find elucidated
in some of the sources
we have for early
cases and controversies
that judges and jurists used
to construct Islamic law.
The fact that
procedures often failed
to make their way into the
normative legal law book
should not obscure
the historical fact
of their existence or of
their prominence historically.
And this becomes clear only
if one examines a wider
array of sources for Islamic law
than has been done previously,
the way historians and
lawyers are trained to do.
If this revised notion of
qadi justice that I tackle
in this new project
means anything,
it calls for rethinking
the methods, and thus
the history and
content of Islamic laws
to encompass more sources
and more procedure.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]